the PlayStation 5 just got a fresh
software update in time for the launch
of its upcoming dual sense Edge
controller which Launches on January
26th for 200 while this patch will only
be a big deal for those looking to pick
up that pricey Pro device the ps5's
eventual 7.0 patch will apparently bring
massive new functionality for all
players according to Insider gaming the
7.0 patch for PS5 will drop in March and
will have two big features full Discord
integration and PS5 game streaming
previously players looking to use
Discord to voice chat on PS5 had to
utilize the popular Services mobile app
but with the 7.0 patch integration would
theoretically work on Playstation like
it now does on Xbox being able to create
and join Discord voice chat right on the
console the other big feature streaming
PS5 games to your PS5 rather than having
to download them and take up space will
be a feature exclusive to premium
members of PlayStation Plus and has been
in testing for several months according
to the same report personally I'd like
the ability to stream my PS5 games via
the cloud to every device but my PS5 but
this is a step in the right direction at
least finally the report states that the
public base of a patch 7.0 will be
starting in the coming days and end
January 30th but that PS5 players that
install it will not have that sweet
sweet full Discord integration during
that period PlayStation 5 players will
likely have the 7.0 patch installed on
their system long before the release of
six time delayed Skull and Bones comes
to the platform which yesterday got
another arbitrary release window of some
time after April 1 this year and before
April 1 2024 if you can believe it
following the announcement we have some
additional details on the game's
progress according to an Ubisoft
spokesperson that spoke with Kotaku the
game itself is complete and the delay is
specifically for polishing and balancing
the report notes that while Ubisoft
Singapore Remains the leads to a quote
Strike team has been assembled to
ubisoft's Main Headquarters in Paris to
help get the game over the Finish Line
important to Note 10 of ubisoft's
development studios are listed as having
worked on the title on its website one
for every year the game has been in
development Ubisoft is likely looking to
avoid a shipwreck of launch much like
Pokemon scarlet and violet which while
selling extremely well has been derided
by press and player alike for being a
technical mess this led to a rare
apology from the Pokemon company
regarding the state of the game with
promises to fix it with upcoming patches
one of which came out in December 2022
although many players were unable to see
a discernible difference in performance
this upcoming patch was revealed
alongside a new video from Nintendo
celebrating the Pokedex crossing the
1000 entry Mark and the update is set to
address bug fixes and add functionality
with further details coming soon please
Nintendo I just want want to play this
game without characters textures and
Pokemon popping in mere feet away from
me that's all I ask at this point what
features would you like added to the PS5
are you happy with Pokemon's performance
at this point in time let us know in the
comments and we'll see you here for more
Gamespot news
[Music]